[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart bran from the
long now foundation and these salt talks
it's an acronym for seminars about
long-term thinking most of the time
we're kind of focusing on the long term
part tonight's about thinking and one of
the people who have done the most
thinking about thinking and the most
realistic and productive way is our
speaker julia calif thank you so much
i'm delighted to be here for several
reasons actually first i've been a fan
of long now foundation for a long time
but there's this other reason i'm
excited to be here which is that I
frequently get people asking me my
origin story like how did I get
interested in this topic thinking about
thinking as Stuart so perfectly put it
why is this you know exciting or
interesting to me and I always hesitate
because the true answer is gonna sound
pretty weird and and so I'm never quite
sure whether to whether to give it or
not but all of you are here with the
long now and and long now as an
organization that adds extra digits to
dates and builds indestructible clocks
and it's just generally kind of weird in
the best possible way so I'm hoping that
you guys might be sufficiently weird
that I can just tell you my true
motivation for being interested in this
topic so here it is um when I was a
child I was very enamored of science
fiction and fantasy novels and TV and
movies and there was this one particular
trope that I found
enthralling and moving and I I didn't
know that it had a name at the time I
guess it didn't have a name at the time
but as I got older years later I found
the perfect name for it in a book by
Keith Stanovich called the robots
rebellion so this trope is it's a trope
of self-determination these are stories
of some creature like a robot or a clone
or Frankenstein's monster that was
created for some purpose and in the
story the creature achieves
self-awareness and comes to learn or
comes to understand how and why it was
created what purpose it was meant to
serve and it wrestles with the knowledge
which is sometimes upsetting or
bittersweet and then sometimes it
decides to go chart its own path
you know the robot decides you know what
I'm not gonna be a soldier or a sexbot
I'm going to try to create a new life
for myself that you know I enjoy and
that's fulfilling to me that I care
about and then the insight that I got
from the robots rebellion and other
books like The Selfish Gene is that this
is also our story this is the story of
humanity we are essentially robots we
are survival machines created by our
genes for the purpose of making copies
of those genes and our genes don't care
about us as individuals for their
purposes we should ideally be spending
our lives always hungry for more
resources
hungry for more status have a bunch of
babies and then die when we're no longer
useful which is a sobering thing to
realize and wrestle with about our own
existence but having realized it we can
choose to rebel we can say you know what
we're going to invent things like the
birth control pill because even though
it may serve our genes goals for us to
be constantly pregnant those aren't our
goals as individuals and the same is
true of our minds we're starting to
understand the ways that our minds are
poorly designed for our goals as people
and the societies that we create and
we're starting to ask okay what should
we do about it and this is a debate that
has stretched out for centuries and has
really heated up in the last few decades
so I'm gonna give you a super-fast
grossly oversimplified summary of this
debate
first man is a rational animal say
historical philosophers and classical
economists actually we're pretty
irrational say cognitive scientists
actually our irrationality is rational
after all say evolutionary psychologists
actually it's not me now I'm not the
only one saying this I just might be the
one saying it loudest and most
insistently
but there are other people too to
varying degrees our making the same
point so that's a sneak peak of the
debate and I'm gonna spend the next 20
minutes or so giving you kind of the
highlights the most important concepts
and arguments in this debate so
originally we saw ourselves as rational
Aristotle famously said something along
these lines that man is a rational
animal and the idea was not that people
are always perfectly rational because
obviously we do stupid things sometimes
you know especially if we're upset or
angry but the idea was that we were
endowed with a capacity for reason and
that made us fundamentally different in
kind from other animals and the purpose
of that capacity for reason was to
achieve truth to examine our beliefs
weigh the logic and the evidence and
come to more accurate conclusions this
is sometimes called the classical or
Cartesian view of reasoning after
Descartes classical economics treats man
as a rational animal in a somewhat
different sense that field assumes that
people process information optimally in
order to make the best decision for
their preferences and again this doesn't
mean that people don't sometimes fail at
this process because they're upset or
distracted or whatever but at least
they're not systematically making
irrational choices is the assumption so
then around the 1960s cognitive
scientists began to show that actually
there are a bunch of ways that our
reasoning fails in predictable ways not
just in occasional random ways and this
is Daniel Kahneman who won a Nobel Prize
for documenting some of these systematic
Reason errors and kick-started the
heuristics and biases field which you
might have read about in books like
Thinking Fast and Slow predictably
irrational or maybe you've just seen all
the lists of cognitive biases floating
around the internet
like overconfidence or anchoring or the
availability heuristic and there's one
especially significant bias really a
whole category of biases that I want to
point out in particular
it's called directionally motivated
reasoning and it is the unconscious
tendency to rely on evidence and
arguments that support a preferred
conclusion more colloquially for desired
conclusions we ask ourselves can I
believe this and for undesired
conclusions we ask must I believe this
the key to recognize here is that we
have a lot of flexibility in how we form
our beliefs and that flexibility gives
us a lot of wiggle room makes it easy
for us to have a double standard for
things that we want to believe versus
things we don't you know we can choose
which sources we find trustworthy we can
choose whether to keep searching for
more evidence or a second opinion or to
just stop with what we have currently
and we can choose how high of an
evidentiary standard we want to apply to
someone's claim so all of those choices
give us a lot of leeway to arrive at
whatever conclusion we want now the
phrase directionally motivated cognition
is not the most catchy term in the world
so I've come to think of this feature in
our cognition as a kind of soldier
mindset that's because it's kind of like
treating ideas as if they were soldiers
on a battlefield with you some ideas or
arguments are on our side and we want to
defend them other ideas or arguments are
a threat and we want to knock them down
or avoid them now maybe some of you are
thinking Julia is it really fair to use
the soldier metaphor surely that isn't
how most people think about reasoning if
so I would like to cordially introduce
you to the English language which begs
to differ according to our own language
the act of reasoning is a brutal bloody
take-no-prisoners war we shoot down
ideas we look we take positions on
issues we look for weaknesses and other
people's positions we defend ideas we
advance arguments and we concede points
which I realize now is like ceding
territory this is an insight that I got
from the book metaphors we live by it by
George Lakoff and I haven't been able to
stop noticing it since then even in my
own language so you're probably already
well
with soldier mindset especially in some
domains like politics where you can just
watch over over years short periods of
years factual questions become polarized
with time for example global warming a
lot of people don't realize that as
recently as twenty years ago this was
not a politically divisive issue
Republicans and Democrats basically
agreed on whether global warming was
happening and then over the subsequent
years it became this political
Shibboleth where it's like an issue
where your belief indicates a lot more
about you than just your best estimate
of the scientific question but rather
your values and what tribe you belong to
so the gap between Democrats and
Republicans widened about thirty five
percentage points in one decade and most
of those people if you ask them would
not say I believe this about global
warming because I'm a Democrat or
because I'm a Republican they would
explain their view by citing sources or
giving logical reasons it's just that
the decision is about which sources are
logic to trust what evidentiary standard
to apply are motivated by political
affiliation so that's a pattern of
beliefs becoming more politically
polarized this is a pattern of beliefs
becoming reverse politically polarized
ten years ago Republicans were much more
likely to see Russia as a threat now
it's the reverse Democrats are more
likely you can probably figure out why
take science scientists almost always
feel like they're they're objectively
pursuing truth but that doesn't mean
that their reasoning isn't being
unconsciously motivated by concerns
about their reputation their funding
sources their career these statistics
are from a paper by John unities and he
knows co-authors found that papers where
at least one of the authors was employed
by a company that produced the drug
being studied were 22 times less likely
to report anything negative about the
drug and a similar thing happens to
maybe slightly less dramatic degrees
across all fields with scientists being
motivated to get significant results so
that they can get published and again a
lot of them will just nearly all of them
I assume will sincerely tell you I'm
just trying to do objective science here
and the problem is just that in any
study there are hundreds of little
choices you have to make about which
hypotheses to test or how to test them
you know what variables should
or should you include this as an outlier
or exclude it there's a ton of room for
you to just unconsciously get the result
you want by asking yourself can I
believe this and avoid the results you
don't want by asking must I believe this
there have also been several studies
where doctors were asked questions like
if you accept gifts from a
pharmaceutical representative would that
bias your decisions about which drugs to
prescribe and the doctors answers in
these studies are basically no but other
doctors might be biased and this effect
is consistent across all sorts of biases
all sorts of test subjects domains we
agree that other people are susceptible
to bias just not us all right I have one
last graph for you about soldier mindset
and it is one of the most important
slides in this talk it's also extremely
depressing are you ready I call it the
graph of despair it's hard to see but I
don't hear anyone breaking out into sob
so I'll have to explain why this is so
depressing this is a graph from a paper
by Dan kahan who said these motivated
reasoning at Yale Law School
and this is again a question about is
global warming happening but the x-axis
this time isn't years it's your level of
science intelligence which kahan defines
as a mixture of scientific knowledge and
numeracy like do you understand basic
math and the more scientifically
literate people are the more their views
are determined by their politics and the
reason this is so depressing is it means
we can't just educate our way out of
these problems you know a lot of people
assume that the reason people disagree
with each other about global warming is
some people just aren't well-informed
enough and this result this graph of
despair just shows how easy it is have
thoroughly you can marshal evidence and
logic to defend almost whatever you want
maybe even especially you know if you're
especially intelligent and clever the
only solution is to want to get it right
and that's really hard
so to recap all of that was me expanding
on the heuristics and biases movement or
at least one major example of it
directionally motivated reasoning the
next stage in the debate is this one
actually irrationality is rational after
all
I wrote evolutionary psychologists on
the slide but the people saying this are
really a combination of evolutionary
psychologists like Robert crews been
here plus people in other fields who
were influenced by evolutionary
psychology like Robin Hanson who's an
economist and there's also separately a
chunk of the field of positive
psychology saying similar things which
I'll talk about know I know
saying irrationality is rational sounds
like you know a Zen koan or a
contradiction but it's not because there
are two types of rationality
instrumental and epistemic so epistemic
rationality means forming beliefs
beliefs about the world that are as
accurate as possible instrumental
rationality means behaving in a way that
helps you achieve your goals or values
and so the claim of this group of people
is that epistemic irrationality is
instrumental irrational in other words
holding false beliefs is often useful
the big evopsych evolutionary psychology
contribution to this grand debate is
that we shouldn't expect that the brain
evolved to be accurate you know just
like any feature of any animal the brain
evolved to give us a survival advantage
to increase the probability that will
pass our genes on to subsequent
generations and sometimes that involves
having accurate beliefs sometimes it
involves having false beliefs this is an
analogy that Kurzban uses in his book
why everyone else is a hypocrite which I
highly recommend his analogy is think of
a nest of baby birds the mama bird
spends her time foraging for food and
she gets as much as she can but it's not
enough to give unlimited food to every
bird so she prioritizes the babies that
are the hungriest the most in danger of
starving now the way that baby birds
communicate how hungry they are is by
tripping and if you're one of the babies
your goal is to get as much food as
possible even if you're not on the brink
of starvation the more food you get the
more you grow up big and strong and able
to thrive so the best strategy for you
is just to chirp as if you're starving
even if you're not and of course the
strategy is not conscious on the part of
the baby birds but sort of built into
the way evolution shapes how birds work
an evolutionary psychologists argue that
there are a lot of equivalent situations
for humans where
having false beliefs makes you better
able to convince other people to give
you resources sharing your tribes
beliefs your political or cultural tribe
makes other people in your tribe see you
as loyal trustworthy likeable being
overly confident that your projects are
going to succeed convinces other people
that you're worth investing in
financially and some evolutionary
psychologists have even argued much less
intuitively that the reason people are
irrationally optimistic about their
health is because it makes other people
more willing to be friends with them the
logic being that people don't want to
invest a lot of time and energy and
someone who's gonna die soon that one's
harder to swallow and when evolutionary
psychologists say that to me I always
sort of squinted their face like are you
serious but I think they are anyway in
theory holding these false beliefs isn't
strictly necessary to reap the benefits
right you could hold accurate beliefs
and then just intentionally deceive
other people the problem is just that
it's really hard to intentionally
deceive other people humans have evolved
to be really good at picking up and
these subtle cues from the way people
hold themselves or behave or the tone of
their voice so the logic goes in order
to be convincing we have to believe it
ourselves so here's a different case for
the existence of strategically false
beliefs this is this one comes from
positive psychology it's like a subfield
of psychic psychology this argument is
that it's good to be irrationally
optimistic about your life and how great
you are not for the persuasion reason
but as a kind of psychological immune
system because it makes you happier more
well-adjusted and one benefit of that is
that it can be a self-fulfilling
prophecy no believing you're likely to
succeed makes you more motivated makes
you put in more effort and that in turn
makes you actually more likely to
succeed there have been hundreds of
articles making points like this and
nearly all of them can be traced back to
a single paper in the psychology
literature from 1988 it's called
illusion and well-being a social
psychological perspective by Shelly
Taylor and Jordan Jonathan Brown it's
one of the most cited papers of all time
in the psych literature when it's
basically a review of a bunch of other
papers which according to Taylor and
Brown show that we must view the
psychologically healthy person not as
someone who sees things as they are but
as someone who sees things
he or she would like them to be as you
can probably tell I'm not fully
convinced and I'll go into more detail
on this research later in the talk it's
actually pretty hilarious mm-hmm
but first let's bring this back to me
the loudest and most insistent proponent
of the argument that soldier mindset is
not actually a good thing to explain my
perspective on this topic I have to
first introduce you to another concept
which you will probably be expecting
given the title of this talk it is the
scout so the soldiers job is to attack
and defend the scouts job is to go out
and get as accurate a map of the
landscape as possible and the scouts may
hope to learn that for example there's a
bridge conveniently located where they
need to cross the river but above all
the Scout just wants to know what's
actually there what's actually true so
if you're in scout mindset you may hope
that you know your business is
succeeding or that you weren't at fault
in a screw-up at work or that you're
making a good impression on your dates
but above all even stronger than those
hopes is a motivation to just know
whatever is actually true rather than
deceive yourself into believing
something that you want to be true and
my argument is that relative to our
defaults we would be better off with
less soldier mindset and more Scout
mindset so the concept that Scout
mindset maps on to in the cognitive
science literature is accuracy motivated
cognition or reasoning reasoning where
you're genuinely trying to figure out
the truth as opposed to directionally
motivated reasoning the study of scout
mindset is pretty new
most of the research so far in this
areas focused on proving the existence
of soldier mindset but you can actually
learn a lot about how Scout mindset
works by looking at the exceptions to
the rule in the studies of soldier
mindset because they're almost always
exceptions so for example you might have
heard of a book called super forecasting
by a political scientist named Phil
tetlock
the origin of this book was Tet Locke's
research showing the people including
so-called experts in political or
economic forecasting where a state lock
put it roughly as accurate as a dart
throwing chimpanzee they're
overconfident they're over simplistic
they don't learn because they won't
admit when they were mistaken
but there were exceptions there was a
small subset of almost entirely amateurs
in tete Lux study who actually were good
at forecasting so much so that they beat
professional intelligence analysts who
had access to classified data about the
world and the amateur forecasters in
tetlock group just had Google when they
wanted to learn about something and they
had no relevant background they were
just really good forecasters so to look
call them the super forecasters and
wrote this book about what were they
doing right and a lot of it is scout
mindset they were willing to acknowledge
when they had been mistaken instead of
rationalizing why they were almost right
or they should have been right
they weren't that invested in any single
ideology so they sought out news from
lots of different perspectives above all
they were just motivated to be accurate
more than they were motivated to defend
a particular idea that they were
attached to or that they had said in the
past you can find Scout mindset poppy-up
in very different domains this is a
great book called deep survival who
lives who dies and why by lawrence
gonzales in which he examines hundreds
of cases of people who got stranded
after hiking or after a plane crash or
shipwreck and his conclusion is that 90%
of people don't make it partly due to
bad luck of course but also due to what
I would call soldier mindsets they
convince themselves they're going to be
rescued so they don't you know conserve
rations or struggle to you know
construct shelter or often they never
prepare for disaster in the first place
out of a kind of if I don't think about
it it won't happen superstition so they
don't bring along proper equipment or
extra water in case of a shipwreck or or
educate themselves about the hazards of
the area where they're hiking that's 90
percent of people but then there are the
exceptions among the 10% who do survive
Gonzales see is this common thread
running through their cases they're the
ones who take precautions in advance who
accept early on that rescuers might
never find them and that they might be
in for a long struggle to survive they
have an accurate picture of their
abilities they don't overestimate their
capabilities they don't underestimate
Gonzalez says the first rule of the
survivors is face reality so you might
have heard this different metaphor
that's kind of similar to salt the
soldier in the Scout which is the lawyer
and the judge there's some similarities
right like lawyers are arguing for one
side the judges role is to figure out
which side is more deserving and be
objective but I want to talk a little
bit about why I like the Scout metaphor
and why I think it sort of adds
important value to the concept the Scout
metaphor emphasizes the usefulness of
having accurate beliefs for the Scout
the whole point of the accurate map is
so that he can use it to navigate the
world better the whole reason that you
should want to know about your strengths
and weaknesses or whether your business
plan is solid or whether you were at
fault is so you can make better
decisions going forward and I think this
is still true even when it isn't obvious
how having an accurate map is going to
benefit you I think it generally pays
off in the long run indirectly for
example I have a friend who I will call
Bob who was home-schooled and his family
raised him to believe in a bunch of
supernatural things like astral
projection energy healing mind-reading
things like that so bob grew up
believing in all of these things and
then one day in his 20s after having
encountered a bunch of skeptics he
decided to research it for himself and
to his surprise you know he had always
assumed that there would be there was
out there good evidence of things like
astral projection but all the stories
that he had heard about you know people
correctly reporting objects in other
rooms because they were projecting
turned out to be inflated or hearsay so
that was like a threat he started
pulling on and over the course of about
a year it began to unravel all of the
other supernatural beliefs now bob was
not seeking any particular benefit from
this investigation other than just the
satisfaction of knowing what was true
but nevertheless I think the
investigation did benefit him for one
thing he now spends less time on
supernatural interventions and more time
on other things that have a better
chance of working but there's this
higher-order benefit to you know having
investigated one pillar of non
scientific claims and seeing it crumble
under scrutiny bob became a little bit
more skeptical of other claims that
contradicted sort of solid established
science which isn't to say that every
single claim that contradicts the
scientific consensus is ness
thoroughly wrong but there's like some
appropriate level of skepticism to apply
to claims that contradict science and
it's higher than what Bob had been
applying and so what that means is that
Bob is now a little bit better equipped
to get the right answer in other domains
like health or psychology he's a little
bit less likely to waste his time on a
medical therapy that you know isn't
gonna work or fall for a scam that's a
real benefit to Bob having an accurate
math of this issue even though Bob never
set out thinking I'm going to
investigate astral projection because I
want to improve my health but I still
haven't addressed the question the
arguments that I showed you a few
minutes ago about the benefits of
positive illusions and strategically
false beliefs so let me do that I'll
start with the positive psychology
argument that soldier mindset is good
for your mood and motivation boost your
morale positive illusions are good for
you there are a lot of problems with the
positive illusions literature but
probably the biggest is that it isn't
about positive illusions the standard
approach in this field is to simply
compare people's perceptions of
themselves to averages so for example
here's one of the tests that is commonly
used in papers about the benefits of
positive illusions people are asked to
rate themselves relative to their peers
on traits like being intellectually self
confidence being anxious being cheerful
being lazy being socially self-confident
and if you rate yourself as being even a
little better than your peers on any of
these metrics you're counted as self
enhancing or holding an unrealistically
positive self-image but of course for
any traits a lot of people are better
than average and the researchers don't
make any effort to check whether you are
in fact more cheerful or more
academically able than your peers the
mere fact that you think you are is
assumed to be a positive illusion then
the researchers look at consequences of
positive illusions for example in one
study they check people for their
reactions to stress and they find that
self enhancers are better at dealing
with stress but since we have no reason
to doubt the reports of most of these
alleged self enhancers all that we've
shown is that people who report being
more cheerful than average and less
anxious
an average tend to deal better with
stress this is not surprising there is
zero need to explain this result with
convoluted logic like people who report
being less anxious are self-deceiving
and that self-deception makes them less
stressed this is the standard approach
other measures of positive Aleutians
don't even ask for a comparison to an
average they just ask you questions like
you know how much do you agree with the
statement on the whole I am satisfied
with myself and if you score highly or
you know you give a high answer to that
your a self enhancer and then they show
that people who score highly on these
metrics also score well in tests of
mental health and conclude that self
enhancement causes mental health if
you're thinking I can't believe the
psychology literary literature is that
bad I thought the same thing I thought I
must be missing something but no there
are other researchers making this point
saying you know guys your papers aren't
actually measuring positive Aleutians
but those papers are not nearly as
widely cited as the papers making errors
in the first place it's really
frustrating guys I just I'm gonna show
you one last metric of self-deception
because it's just hilarious so in this
paper which this metric has been used by
several papers but not as many as the
others they asked questions like does
every attractive person of the opposite
sex turn you on do you ever feel
attracted to people of the same sex have
you ever wanted to rape or be raped by
someone and you're supposed to answer
from one meaning not at all to seven
very much so
and if you answer with a one or two that
counts a self-deception so if you have
never wanted to rape or be raped or even
if you have rarely wanted to rape or be
raped
you're a self deceiver I just I know I
said this is hilarious and it is but it
also just makes me genuinely angry like
how bad this stuff is and how widely
it's cited I just I can't even I have to
move on all right let's talk instead
about the evolutionary psychology
argument that soldier mindset helps you
persuade other people that you're
correct and competent and so on so my
takin brief is that overconfidence being
falsely confident that you're right or
that you're skilled or whatever can be
effective
how much so depends on a few things
first how sophisticated is your audience
if your audience doesn't have a good
intuition for what is a reasonable claim
in that domain in particular you can get
away with a lot more exaggeration so
let's say you're a consultant and you
confidently tell a potential client all
the advice I've given my past clients
has worked out extremely well they're
all much more successful than they were
before thanks to me you definitely won't
regret hiring me well if your client is
not that sophisticated he might be super
impressed by that if your client is more
sophisticated he's likely to think to
himself really all of her past clients
were more successful that seems
implausible since you know it's hard to
make business decisions and there's a
lot of luck involved
this consultant seems kind of delusional
so part of the strategic calculus about
scout versus soldier mindset for
persuasion boils down to how
sophisticated is your audience and do
you care more about being persuasive to
sophisticated people or unsophisticated
people and I'm using that term
specifically to mean sort of
sophistication about reasoning in a
particular domain then there's the
question of does your audience have an
incentive to figure out if you're right
you know if you're a financial advisor
to someone for example they definitely
have an interest in trying to figure out
if you're being overconfident because
it's their money at stake but on the
other hand if you're a talk show hosts
your fans are probably not that
interested in double-checking your
claims to find out if you're uncharted
ly misrepresenting the politician they
hate and finally how obvious is it going
to be if you are actually wrong if you
make overconfident predictions about say
tomorrow's weather it becomes quickly
clear that you are overconfident but if
you say overconfident things about the
far future it won't become clear you
were wrong in people's lifetimes so
basically the ideal career choice if you
want to be overconfident is to be a guru
for an unsophisticated audience telling
them that they're going to have the best
afterlife
to sing
I also think it's worth noting the
advantages that Scout mindset has in
being persuasive so this is one of my
opinion the most impressive acts of
persuasion in history Charles Darwin's
book on the origin of species an account
of how species evolved through natural
selection it was a controversial
bombshell when it was published in the
1860s as Darwin knew it would be the
theory of evolution threatened the
sacred unviable worldview in which
species were immutable and organized
into a design hierarchy with humans at
the top
Darwin told a friend while he was
preparing the book that arguing for
evolution felt like confessing a murder
so the book sparked years of furious and
often emotional debate but Darwin's case
was so solid so full of years of
carefully collected observations and
well reasoned arguments that it ended up
persuading people within a decade the
majority of the scientific
establishments believed in evolution and
the reason that darwin's case was so
convincing even to an audience with a
strong bias against it was that Darwin
had Scout mindsets he bent over
backwards while writing the book to
notice arguments and evidence that went
against his theory he followed what he
called a golden rule of research to
fight against motive motivated reasoning
I had also he wrote during many years
followed a golden rule namely that
whenever a published fact a new
observation or a thought came over me
which was opposed to my general results
to make a Memorandum of it without
failing at once because I had found by
experience that such facts and thoughts
were far more apps to escape from the
memory than favorable ones so Darwin
basically stressed tested his theory for
years within an inch of its life trying
to notice all of the potential
objections to it and modifying and
improving the theory until it was really
solid and that's what made him so
persuasive if he had instead tried to
just convince himself that he was
totally right and you know win the day
by the power of confidence I don't think
he would have succeeded so basically I
think of overconfidence as a crutch it
might help you in some situations for
sure but if you don't allow yourself to
indulge in it then you force yourself to
become actually competent you force
yourself to improve your theories until
they're actually solid and that works
better in the long run there's a book
called confidence
by Tomas tomorrow / music that makes
basically this point he says we mostly
have been brainwashed into thinking that
confidence will eventually cause
competence I think it's much more
appropriate to think of confidence as a
compensatory strategy for lower
competence and by the way it's funny to
read reviews of this book on Amazon
because it's it's called confidence and
they're all these reviewers who are like
one-star I bought this book cause I
wanted to learn how to be confident me
all this whole point is like no you
shouldn't do that so I think if you want
to be influential and persuasive which
is a fine thing to want to be then in
addition to actually developing your
skill you should look for other ways to
be charismatic and persuasive that don't
come at the cost of damaging your mental
models of the world like improve your
posture and your speaking voice your
general presentation learn good social
skills expand your social comfort zone
through practice interestingly I just
came across paper called when
overconfidence is revealed to others
testing the status enhancement theory of
overconfidence by Anderson and at all
and from the abstract it seems to be
making the case that overconfidence is
useful that it makes you influential and
higher status and to be clear it's
measuring actual overconfidence like
relative to your performance on tests
not some [ __ ] metric think it's
called overconfidence merely if you
claim to be good at something sorry I'm
still mad about that but if you actually
read the paper there's a striking table
of the factors that increased people's
social status in these groups and the
actual measures of overconfidence per se
like how confident you said you were in
your claims how easy you claimed that
the task was for you and how confident
you claimed to be those are the
highlighted ones at the bottom they were
either not significant or barely
significant the things that mattered the
things that increased your status in the
group were the social things did you
participate a lot in the conversations
was your tone of voice confidence did
you seem relaxed and at ease and may be
you know it could well be the case that
being overconfident in your beliefs or
your skills is one mechanism that causes
those traits but it's certainly not the
only one and it seems much better to me
to just develop those
skills directly rather than trying to
deceive yourself into believing you're
totally right and awesome in order to
get social confidence as a side effect
all right here's an arguments that
people sometimes makes me they say let's
get the best of both worlds let's turn
on soldier mindset sometimes when it's
useful like being Scout mindset when
you're picking a business plan but then
once you've picked it turn on soldier
mindset and believe it's definitely
gonna succeed or you know be in soldier
mindset when you need to persuade people
and Scout mindset when you need to make
tough decisions here's why I'm somewhat
skeptical of that approach when
President Lyndon Johnson was a senator
he had this ritual that his aides called
working up so he would start with
something he wanted to believe something
that would be convenient for him to
believe and then he would repeat it to
himself again and again and again
willing himself to believe it by the
time he was done he was able to argue
that position with utter conviction and
insist
apparently in earnest that he had never
believed anything different and it was
effective people called him the greatest
salesman one on one who ever lived but
the question is could he switch into
scout mindset when he had to make tough
decisions and not just persuade people
he certainly tried to so when he assumed
the presidency and inherited the Vietnam
War from Kennedy he put together a group
of advisers to give him multiple
informed perspectives on what to do
sounds like Scout mindset the problem
though was that even though he believed
in theory that it was good to be open
minded and hear dissenting opinions he
really hated doing it he was not good at
the skill of hearing disagreement well
or dealing with difficult or
inconvenient truths he would get angry
at people who said things that he didn't
want to hear like we can't win in
Vietnam we need to pull out so his
advisors would either learn to bite
their tongues or he would start to
exclude them from meetings or from the
administration if he didn't like their
opinions
the real wake-up call to Johnson should
have been when his Secretary of Defense
Robert McNamara finally changed his mind
about the war this was a man who had
been a loyal member of the Johnson's
administration of the president's an
inner circle a man who Johnson respected
who had been pro war for years and
and reluctantly come to the conclusion
that war simply wasn't working when
someone like that begins to voice doubts
out your plan that should prompt some
genuine soul-searching instead it only
made Johnson angry historian David
Halberstam wrote about McNamara's
dissent quote the president still
described his defense secretary as
brilliant but there was a new sarcastic
touch to it in mid nineteen sixty seven
when McNamara proposed limiting the Bob
bombing gradually reduced hidden scale
as a means of getting negotiations
started Johnson took the proposals
handed them to an aide and said you've
never seen such a lot of [ __ ] by the way
it is amusing to compare this account of
the event to Johnson's account in his
memoir he says I studied McNamara's memo
carefully he made a cogent case for the
actions he proposed though I disagreed
with some arguments and questioned some
assumptions I was convinced that his
proposal deserved thoughtful attention a
few months later Johnson picked McNamara
out of the administration without
warning he announced it in public and
McNamara had to pretend not to be
surprised and the war raged on so
Johnson basically thought he was doing
the Scout mindset thing thought he was
doing the like careful deliberation
open-minded here a dissenting opinions
thing but he just like was not suited to
it
of course Johnson is just an N of one
he's an anecdote the question of how
easy is it to switch back and forth
between soldier and scout mindsets is an
open empirical question and I'm trying
to have Scout mindset about how broadly
valuable Scout Minds it is so it is
totally possible that more research
could change my mind about this but I
want to explain why it seems to me just
a priori like it would be difficult to
do the switching between modes thing
I'll use an analogy when you're driving
on an icy road and your car starts to
skid your reflex is to hit the brakes
that's exactly the wrong thing to do it
only makes your car spin faster out of
control what you're supposed to do
instead is to steer into the skid turn
the steering wheel of the car in the
same direction as the back end of the
car is spinning it's a really tough
thing to remember on the spot because
it's so counterintuitive and B your
adrenaline is pumping and you have to do
something fast so really the only way to
do it reliably is through practice
and soldier mindset is also a reflex a
set of related reflexes really
rationalizing defending dismissing
feeling resentful or offended when
people disagree
so soldier mindset I see it as like
slamming the brakes when you start to
skid it's this thing you do reflexively
even though it's counterproductive in
the long run or the very short run with
the car and then Scout mindset is this
other set of habits or reflexes that can
sometimes override the soldier reflexes
if you've practiced them like
considering a counter argument or
remembering not to be defensive or
checking yourself for bias or like
questioning your first impression and
they're a little counterintuitive
they're a little bit unnatural and
they're harder to do when your
adrenaline is high when you're you know
upset or aroused so if you rarely
practice them just like steering into
the skid it's gonna be really hard to
just whip them out and do them reliably
when you need to now I know I've been
disagreeing with the evolutionary
psychologists but I'm actually really
grateful to them for highlighting the
importance of incentives and reasoning
for asking like what is the goal of the
organism when it's using its brain this
is something that's so often ignored all
too often people talk about informing
the public or improving education as
solutions to our problems and I just
don't think that's gonna help that much
you know we try lecturing kids about
logical reasoning or you know checking
claims that you find on the Internet
considering alternative hypotheses but
that may increase their ability to be
accurate but it doesn't increase their
incentive to be accurate right you know
if there's no payoff from getting the
right answer either material payoff or a
social payoff or an emotional payoff why
should they bother expending the effort
to do so on the flip side if they still
face the same incentives to reach a
particular conclusion you know it's a
signal loyalty to their tribe or to look
strong to look consistent and so on
then they're gonna continue to pursue
those incentives no matter how much
knowledge and information we give them
about you know the correct answers are
the correct way to reason this is not a
problem we can educate our way out of
just to remind you of the graph of
despair hmm
I'm more optimistic about approaches
that actually affect those incentives
prediction markets for example like
predicted are a way to offer people
rewards for getting the right answer
instead of just defending whatever you
know makes them look good or feel good
and the long now foundation was actually
ahead of the game
way back in I think 2003 15 years ago
they created long baths so that people
could put their money where their mouth
was when talking about the future I want
to see more things like this those are
material incentives but social approval
and attention are also really powerful
incentives one culture that gets this
right is actually a forum on reddit
which might surprise you because reddit
is not known for being a know a waste of
scout mindset but um the subreddit is
it's called changed my view and it was
created in 2013 by Col Turnbull who was
then just a high school student as of
now they have over half a million
subscribers and our change my view does
what it says on the tin people come to
the forum with a view that they are at
least open to changing and other people
argue with them perhaps the most unique
aspect of change my view is the Delta
system so when you make an argument that
the like if someone else has submitted
an argument and you respond to them and
the submitter finds your response
convincing and it changes their mind
even a little bit like you know this
this one premise of my argument is like
less solid than I thought or hmm that's
like an alternate perspective that I
hadn't considered it's interesting
anything like that any the thing that
alters their perspective a little bit
they can choose to award you a delta
it's just a little triangle shaped icon
that goes next to your user name
signifying you change their mind and as
you rack up Delta's your total count is
displayed next to your name whenever you
post and people really want to earn
deltas technically they're just made up
maybe nothing but on the other hand so
our points in a video game and people
you know really want are in those
Delta's are a manifestation of your
reputation unchanged my view they make
people more likely to respect to you to
pay attention to you to read what you
say and one interesting result of the
Delta system is that
the best practices for minds changing
rise to people's attention and spread
throughout the change my view community
so as new members join the subreddit
they notice hey I'm not earning as many
deltas as I'd like to or as other people
are what are those other people doing
right and so they study you know the
high Delta earners comments and
arguments and copy what they're doing so
for example top Delta earners are less
combative in their disagreements they're
more likely also to ask clarifying
questions before trying to argue with
someone and other members especially new
members notice these behaviors notice
they're successful at earning deltas
copy them and then the practices spread
this is kind of similar to what the open
science community is doing so I
mentioned earlier in the talk how
scientists are motivated to get results
that are significant they can publish
this has been a simmering problem for
many decades that just recently boiled
over in the social sciences especially
in what's in terms of the replication
crisis so tons of seemingly solid
findings that people had trusted for
years turned out not to be real not to
replicate when people tried to do the
same experiments so this is depressing
but there are a bunch of scientists who
are trying to fix the problem and
they're pretty savvy about getting the
incentives right I think for example
these are badges open science badges and
they work kind of like Delta's you get
awarded a badge if you share your data
from your experiment if you pre-register
your experiments would mate which makes
it much harder to you know fiddle with
the data and make a bunch of little
choices to get a result that you want
and they're also changing the social
incentives more directly so people who
do rigorous things like share their data
or acknowledge when they were wrong get
a flood of social approval on social
science Twitter and also I mean that's
like the carrot than the stick is people
who are kind of slippery or sketchy
about their papers you know who like
refused to admit that their results
didn't replicate or who you know had
been shown to be pea hacking to be like
fiddling with their data they get social
disapproval now in a way that they
didn't before and I think the internet
helps with this but it's also just the
result of the
concerted movement on the part of the
people who care about improving the
epistemic sub science to make sure
they're applying social pressure in the
right ways and so it's slowly becoming
more desirable more incentivized to try
to actually do good science and not just
get your papers published before I wrap
up we're here with the long now
foundation thinking about our long-term
future and I wanted to say a few words
about how soldier and scout mindsets are
in play and thinking about the future
so one thing that you'll notice if you
pay attention to conversations about our
future is that there are self-proclaimed
optimists and then pessimists who
sometimes call themselves cynics or
realists and both groups wave their
label as if it's a flag self-described
optimists pride themselves on seeing the
good in the world and on being
enthusiastic and likeable self-described
cynics pride themselves on not being
dupes and on facing hard truths
optimists and cynics might not be
official political parties but they
share a disdain for each other that
rivals the mutual disdain between
Republicans and Democrats optimists
talking about pessimists use words like
doomsayer alarmist shrill paranoid and
Chicken Little as in the sky is falling
and then in turn pessimists talking
about optimists use words like Pollyanna
naive deluded or Pangloss who's the
character in Voltaire's Candide who
provided comic relief by stubbornly
insisting that this was the best of all
possible worlds even as great tragedy
happened around him and both sides feel
like the embattled minority both
optimists and pessimists view their own
position as the more difficult and
demanding and demonstrative of strength
of character so cynics or pessimists
will say things like the perennial II
naive optimist wants to be liked by all
and offend none this is a quote
meanwhile optimists say things like
despite how easy it would be to choose
cynicism I choose to believe in
humanity's inherent goodness or it's far
too easy to be negative about everything
incidentally have you noticed that
optimists often talk with pride about
how they choose to be optimists or how
they identify as optimists it's an
interesting wording like you wouldn't
say I
choose to believe that the store is open
or I identify as someone who believes
that the store is open you would just
say the store is open my point is that
if people had no identity invested in
being optimistic they wouldn't say like
I choose to believe that things turn out
well or identify as someone who believes
things turn out well they would just say
things tend to turn out well so I think
that when we talk about whether we're
optimistic or pessimistic about the
future a lot of the times with large
extent we're not talking about how we
think the world works we're not talking
about you know what does the landscape
look like what should we put on our map
in order to be accurate we're talking
about what kind of people we are and
what we value it's a perfect storm for
soldier mindset and it really is
important I think to be able to think
honestly and accurately to the best of
our abilities about the future questions
like what is the risk of a nuclear war
is climate change something we could fix
with technology is globalization making
the world better these are empirical
questions and it matters whether our
guesses are roughly accurate or not you
know if we are too sanguine about the
risk of a catastrophe that's definitely
bad on the other hand if we
underestimate the positive benefits of
something then we might never try it and
not reap those benefits so I'm sure
you've all been paying rapt attention
this whole time but I'm just gonna recap
briefly before I end my talk so to recap
we are robots but we can rebel our
brains are built to treat important
questions as tribal fights or as threats
to our ego or status but we can change
that education doesn't help because of
the graph of despair having an oh we
need to be incentivized to be accurate
having an accurate map of the world is
useful and it doesn't mean you can't
have more alum status and finally some
psychology papers are really bad just so
bad you guys thank you
[Applause]
it's not like you might have a little
more to say at the end there was that I
always afford to say okay since one of
the measures of scout mindset which you
must have mastered by now is changing
one's mind of course the obvious
question is must have gotten before what
did you change your mind about ah have
to clean this room but any room really
counts um I mean I've definitely changed
my mind about aspects of scout mind
sighs um I well so I've been working on
this book about basically what I
discussed in the talk and and it was
really hard especially at first for me
to you know I've been doing interviews
with people who start companies or you
know who doing all sorts of things just
trying to understand how scout and
solder mines that works for them and I I
noticed that I was really reluctant to
interview people who I thought were
going to disagree with my thesis and
talk about you know how it was great to
be super overconfident and how you have
to you know never think about any doubts
and things like that so I would avoid
interviewing those people or or when I
did interview them I would I noticed
myself asking them like leading
questions like no so tell me about a
time when change your mind was really
useful or tell me and I wouldn't ask the
questions like you know have you found
any downsides to like facing the truth
or like have you found overconfidence be
useful or things like that
so I I had to do kind of an intervention
on myself you know in the talk how does
that work yeah well so this is the whole
thing I consider talking about in the
talk and decided to cut it for time but
I talked about incentives at the end I
talked about mostly external incentives
like being financially rewarded for your
forgetting the right answer or being
rewarded with social attention and
approval things like that but internal
incentives as I call them are also
extremely powerful like feeling you know
curious or excited to learn things like
my friend Bob did in
in the story about supernatural beliefs
or in the opposite direction feeling you
know stressed out or or uncomfortable
with possibilities and so I think a lot
of the like as an individual wanting to
improve boost your levels of scout
mindset as opposed to someone designing
systems in society or you know
subcultures I think one of the best and
easiest things you can do is just try to
change your internal incentives so that
was what I was trying to do in my
investigation of scout mindset so
basically the thing that I usually do is
I ask myself like before I'm before I
try to think about whether some
inconvenient possibility is true I try
to just say okay suppose it is true what
then like what happens then so like if I
were you know considering whether or not
I had to fire someone and I was really
stressed out about it and tempted to
like rationalize why I didn't have to
fire them not anymore
[Laughter]
so in this case the thing that I was
worried about was that people were gonna
tell me that overconfidence was really
useful for them and so I was like okay
what if that is true what does that
turns out to be true what then
I was like well it's not like it would
sink my book like a I can allow
exceptions you know my book doesn't have
to claim that Scout mind is always
correct and B I can disagree with them
like the fact that some people might
think that Scott mindset is not as
useful as I think it is doesn't know
basically every interesting book has had
people disagreeing with it it's like
almost no exceptions so that that was
like a useful thing to think about and
it made me much more sanguine about
asking people non leading questions and
facing the possibility of getting
answers that I might not like I guess
the thing I want to say is just that
there's a difference between having
preferences about what is true and being
unable to tolerate something being the
case
and so the purpose of interventions like
this is to move yourself from like being
unable to face a world in which it is
true that whatever like you know people
disagree with me versus a world in which
like well that's not what I wanted but
like I'm I'm okay I think that's a
really valuable intervention to boost
Scout mindset and so an answer to your
original question which I almost
completely failed to answer the the
thing that I changed my mind about was
just like how how often people at least
perceive it to be the case that
overconfidence is helpful to them
no I've you know I have my thoughts some
of which I shared in the talk about why
I think they might be wrong or
misperceiving things or why there might
be other better ways to get the things
that they think they're getting from
overconfidence but but I certainly
acknowledge now that's overconfidence
it's more popular than I heard you say
do people vote for scout soldiers yeah
it's a great question a lot of the
difficulty and answering questions about
like our scouts or soldiers more
successful in you know business or
politics or whatever is that there
aren't really that many Scouts so I mean
I use the phrase of scouts and soldiers
often just kind of as a shortcut figure
of speech
it's not like some people are Scouts and
some people are soldiers it's a spectrum
we all have varying degrees of scout and
solider mindset and it changes from day
to day or depending on what domain we're
thinking about but but there aren't that
many people who are like shining
exemplars of scout mindset and so let me
raise one and see how that plays ok
which is most politicians that I've been
you know watch tend to see well as I've
always said
mm-hm and then they repeat some notion
they have I worked for Jerry Brown
during his first administration oh you
know the state friends and the second
administration one of the peculiarities
of Jerry Brown which I think he learned
from Jesuits that he trained with
and hold idea of the devil's advocate
being taken seriously as I saw in person
sometimes too might discomfort Jerry
taking the opposing argument to the
obvious thing that should be decided yes
and he would just defend the other
beauty or go out and find somebody who
would defend the other view so for
example there was a California
metrication counsel and he knew I was
against the total conversion to metric
so he put me on the California
metrication killing and thanks to Ronald
Reagan I was successful we do not truly
change and he let it be known that he
would occasionally change his mind or he
would say things like you know I don't
think the debaters really mature on this
subject yeah and let's see how it plays
out a little longer we're not in a hurry
to make a decision on this because what
comes to a governor or a president's
desk is basically unsolvable problems
all the solvable ones get dealt with
yeah the levels of government and and he
does not get punished for that in the
voting and he's not long on charm he's
pretty good on charisma and he's tricky
you don't know what the hell he's
talking about sometimes and sometimes
he's figuring it out you know in person
in front of you so all of this is not
classic soldier behavior at all yeah and
yet he did okay and yet he's also pretty
rare I think to your point yeah I mean
there are there are exceptions in both
successful and unsuccessful politicians
so like one person who comes to mind I
think it was Barry Goldwater who he was
not a super successful politician but he
defended Bill Clinton when Clinton was
being he was under attack for which
scandal was it wasn't
I'm blanking on which scandal maybe
sorry did someone say something water
yes
wait water I think it was white water
and and and Goldwater was like like
called a press conference oh he's super
conservative he called a press
conference just to say that people
should lay off of Bill Clinton because
it was the evidence was not strong
against him and you should just like let
him do his job and this is like
scandalized a bunch of people and made
him a bunch of enemies there are I mean
I think Obama has given like their case
of Obama being pretty scout like yeah
he's talked about his process of writing
speeches and said you know some people
are most some people are able to be
compelling and convincing sort of no
matter what they believe like saying
something that they don't necessarily
believe for me it's much easier to give
a compelling speech if I've like edited
it until I feel like I couldn't really
stand behind it any sort of a pretty
careful reasoner even you know Ronald
Reagan sort of had had more of the
classic like like like be charismatic
and tell people what they you know
what's gonna make them happy and things
like that but he also had some examples
of Scout mindset he was a big fan of I
think was FDR's New Deal which is not
like a classical thing for a
conservative to be a fan of but he he
just grew up admiring FDR and he you
know would give interviews where he's
like you know what FDR was really
misunderstood and like you know I
disagree with him about some things but
he had all these admirable virtues who
really brought the country together and
that was really great so you know there
are example like it's not impossible to
be a successful politician and do some
Scout like things that said you know
when I was talking about the types of
factors that make a difference in
whether Scout or whether overconfidence
is going to be successful in persuading
people being a politician kind of checks
a lot of those boxes like the audience
is not sophisticated almost by
definition because it's just like the
entire country you know it's not like a
special set of
you know experts people are not I guess
they're a little motivated to decide if
you're you know telling lies or
something but with like tribalism
they're not that motivated and a lot of
the things you say people will find out
if they were true or not maybe years
later maybe if anyone's paying attention
a lot of the things you say aren't
aren't even like testable predictions
they're just sort of like in like
effective expressions about the country
or about people or things like that so I
think politics is is definitely a case
where Scout mindset is like less able to
thrive Bob also asks can there be other
players besides Scouts and soldiers I
mean the kid in me who loves sci-fi and
fantasy is getting very excited at
having a richer menagerie of characters
I think I mean an important point that
may not have been clear from the way I
explained it in the talk is that
Scotland soldier mindsets aren't like a
mutually exhaustive thank you yes
they don't exhaust the space of possible
you know ways you can be thinking so
here's an example when I mentioned the
case of someone like choosing a business
plan and then executing on it so a lot
of people will say like well you should
try to be in soldier mindset while
you're executing on your plan if you can
and I would say no the ideal like you
it's true you don't want to be
constantly questioning and
second-guessing yourself and you know
reevaluating your core assumptions of
your business because that would be
exhausting and you'd never get anything
done but ideally what I think you should
do is just decide okay I'm gonna be an
execution mode for a while maybe that's
you know a month or six months or what
depends on your business and the stage
you're at and if a doubt comes up or
like if a concern or a piece of
evidence comes up I'm gonna be like okay
maybe maybe that's the thing maybe
that's a concern I'm not gonna think
about it right now I'll like reevaluate
later in the future and so and then you
do you know reevaluate later in the
future maybe at some point six months
later you're like well the accumulated
concerns and flaws in the plan that have
come up in the last six months now make
me think that you know this might be a
problem yeah
right but but the key is that what
you're doing is just like deciding not
to make any decisions now instead of the
soldier mindset thing to do which would
be to find some reason why those
concerns are false or you know or
unwarranted or something like that to
like convince yourself that's everything
that's definitely still great and I
think that approach to dealing with
potential flaws or obstacles that come
up is just more damaging to your
epistemic health some of that is
situational when I was twenty years of
global business Network where we were
purveying scenario planning which is a
great way to get companies sort of out
of the soldier mindset of this is our
theory of the future and we're offering
the whole business and service of that
theory and they get all kinds of
confirmation bias and all the rest of it
what is this - a tional planning I'm
sorry what is situational planning
well what situational is large companies
really really gain from scenario
planning startups don't sort of like us
here's the situation a large company or
a department of government or even a
whole government the case of Singapore
often has sort of set itself in motion
with a theory of the world which is
playing up very well thank you but the
world keeps changing and if they keep
going with this same sort of strategic
scheme they will not be alert to changes
in the world and they will not figure
that they're supposed to be alert and
they're supposed to adapt to changes in
world
it was huge success and what's very
planning allows them to do is have more
than one theory of the world series the
world any which might be right if
they're totally plausible but they imply
completely different things that they
might be facing in the next five ten or
fifteen years a start-up has the theory
of the world
mm-hmm which scenarios are not going to
help them is just gonna confuse them and
we found that we're not particularly
useful to them because five or ten years
is a start up is just trying to get
circuit with the world just trying to
get something that it's feeding your
incentive to keep going and you survive
as a business or as a nonprofit or
whatever and so you're making a
full-bore bet on your theory of the
world which may or may not you're right
sometimes just the fact it's a full-bore
well bet will convince the world that
there's something they are so there's
part of the conference thing but anyway
I'm seeing a situational about it it's a
small organization or individual is
maybe not gonna gain by scenario
planning as much as a great big thing
which has to you which is going to take
ten years to turn the ship mmm give it a
big company has a really tough time
pivoting I see so yours okay let me make
sure I understand so you're saying that
scenario planning is less useful to a
startup um in part because situational
planning is useful if you can't just
adapt to new situations when they happen
which larger companies can't as easily
right and also I think you're saying
startups have less sort of attention and
organizational capacity to spare and
sort of history all they can really do
is just like make their one bet yeah as
opposed to a large company with lots of
and then also you know the cost of
failure first startup in most cases is
much smaller than the cost of failure
for a larger organization again in the
or as you're using the actually Philip
tetlock you refer to has been in this
series twice one was about the super
forecasting book and he uses his real
brilliance Hedgehog in the Fox they talk
as one big idea in the Fox has many
ideas yeah any further you know sort of
plays it out further hedgehogs are very
persuasive because they know all the
arguments for their particular thing and
the Fox is kind of tentative and not as
good on television and you know the
super forecasters are all kind of
dialing back the clarity of their
statement because they're saying why
that might actually be occurring so be
accurate there's to be a little fuzzy
and so you buy a lot from Jeff Locke but
the hedgehog and foxes speak to you yeah
so there's two separate things going on
here I think one is the what is the how
tentative you sound and that I think is
like you you can you can be bold and
confident while still having nuanced
models so like for example I have I have
a friend who he he kind of this story to
me so he was he was talking to a friend
of his
I'll make the friend female just because
it's easier pronouns okay so he was
telling his friend about how it was
important to be you know change your
mind and update your beliefs and so on
and the friend was like what are you
talking about you never changed your
mind and my friend was like are you
kidding I changed my mind all the time
in fact there are two instances I can
remember where I changed my mind with
you in this you know like in the last
month and he explained them and she was
like that's true actually you did change
your mind why did that not register for
me as examples of you changing your mind
and she thought about it and she was
like you know I think it's because you
were just so unfazed like it didn't you
didn't seem sheepish you didn't you're
just like oh yeah that's right I was
wrong about that and then you
went on and so my mind didn't store it
as an example of you having been wrong
and I I know people I know others I mean
it's you you can do the like enthusiasm
and gratitude for having you know been
shown to be wrong but a lot of this is
just extremely nonchalant like oh yeah I
was wrong about that
you know now I think X instead of Y or
something you know I think here's what I
think it suggests I think it suggests
that well sorry it probably suggests
that it wasn't like an extremely weighty
emotionally fraught topic to you that's
true
but it might you still might have had a
confident belief about it like a 90%
sure that X was true and then realized
oh wait no y is true
I think the nonchalance is really
helpful it makes it makes change your
mind really easy and effortless and
frictionless and the source I think of
that nonchalance is I mean I've asked
people about it who had this nonchalant
approach and when I ask them questions
like why do you not feel sheepish when
you change your mind they tend to sort
of look taking the back and then they
shrug and they're like well I didn't do
anything wrong like I am following the
right process for you know forming
beliefs and evolving them over time and
that ideal process just by its very
nature it will involve like changing
like as you get new information or as
you reevaluate old information you will
notice things that you were wrong about
and but that's you doing the right thing
that's not you having screwed up
I mean sometimes it might it might
sometimes be you having screwed up it
might be that like in the past you had
all the information you needed to be
right and you were just like refusing to
see it or something like that but most
of the time when these people change
their minds like no I got new
information
I like reevaluated now I think this
other thing and it's just like they're
just doing the process things are
tougher to change my mind about because
they imply a whole bunch of other things
inserts a cascade of oh my gosh have I
changed my mind about climate then I've
got to be able come in democratic yeah
and yeah if you perceive a cascade that
potentially would make you cling to the
soldier point of view on something much
more strongly yes yeah so I a thing I
believe that might sound surprising is
that in most cases it is actually wrong
to change your mind about a sort of
fundamental belief you know in response
to like one discussion or you know one
argument or something like that because
like like if you're following the
correct intellectual process this will
almost never happen and and you know
often maybe that's the result of soldier
mindset but even if you're doing
everything right it would not happen
very often the reason is you know our
beliefs are all as you were saying
they're all sort of connected to each
other they're like this network of of
interconnected beliefs that are all kind
of dependent on each other and so you
know something like climate change
there's a bunch of beliefs that are
related to that like let's say you don't
believe climate change is real there's a
bunch of related beliefs that that that
belief depends on like scientists are
not that trustworthy or or like other
experts maybe religious experts or or
other sources of authority are
trustworthy or maybe there's a belief
about how common is it for conspiracy
theories to happen
because like a lot of people who don't
believe that climate change is happening
think that there's sort of a conspiracy
among climate scientists to to like say
the false thing and so if you believe
that conspiracy conspiracies are
actually pretty common then it's like
more reasonable to believe that it could
be the case that climate scientists are
all covering this up and so for you to
justifiably change your mind about
climate science you would need to change
your mind about a bunch of other things
too and that can almost never happen in
one conversation that's like like even
if you're doing everything right and
you're like you have Scott mindset
that's a process that would take a long
time okay so related to that bowler ass
did your suggestion that people not
change their mind about important things
of conversation yes have you found a way
to award Delta's to people in real life
and your yeah yeah I mean well this one
is kind of silly but in some groups of
friends or like at the organization I
used to work with we just had this hand
symbol it was like wiggling fingers it
was just a sign I'm not suggesting
everyone do this I'm just telling you
you asked so it was just a gesture of
like approval
sometimes agreement sometimes just like
approval or you know it was just like a
you know karma points or something like
that and we would just do that whenever
we noticed someone in conversation doing
like an epistemic Lee virtuous thing
like you know acknowledging that someone
else had a point or or sometimes like
phrasing their statements in a way that
that could be falsified like most of the
things we say aren't precise enough that
anyone could ever prove us wrong so if
someone said like no I'll like like
that's that'll never work something like
that and then it's like okay what I
actually predict is that within two
months like revenue will be XYZ or
something would you like okay good
testable prediction or like I don't know
someone being willing to make a bet
these are all things that we made it's
just like so you don't interrupt the
conversation and it's and and like the
hend gesture started to be infused with
like positive effect because of the
Association so you'd like actually feel
good sort of like with Delta's I mean in
like real life you should probably just
like tell someone that you think it's
cool that they did the thing
yeah clarity transparency I mean sorry
you should also like be more willing to
like share stuff online from people who
do the good things and you know if you
run a company or a team of people like
be more willing to reward people with
like attention or promotions or things
like that when they you know make
accurate predictions are you know are
willing to like say like here are the
potential downsides of my plan like I
think we should do it anyway but I'm
gonna like be intellectually honest and
not pretend that it has no downsides
like those are the kinds of things you
should be rewarding ya in science
there's the story basically this has got
some going when scientists do that and
it's rare but when they do it all other
scientists that's a story about that
some people might have heard me say this
before it's one of my favorite stories
but this was it at Oxford in the zoology
department in I think the 1970s and at
the time in the field of zoology there
was this debate over the existence of
this particular cellular structure
called the Golgi apparatus the debate
was is it actually real or is it like an
artefact an illusion of measurement or
observation and there was this like
elderly distinguished professor in the
zoology department at Oxford whose
position was it's not real it's an
artifact of observation and then one day
this younger American professor visited
Oxford and gave a talk to the department
where he presented new and very
compelling evidence that the Golgi
apparatus was in fact real and so
throughout
talk all the other scientists are kind
of like looking over their shoulder at
the older professor like what's he gonna
say how's he taking this and at the end
of the talk
the older professor strode up to the
front of the lecture hall and extended
his hand to the young professor and said
my dear sir thank you you've shown me
that I've been wrong for 15 years and
everyone burst into applause and cheers
and I still tear up so Kevin Kelley has
a question of course it's Steven Pinker
you first you argue the Scout mindset
would reveal that optimism is warranted
because progress in the world is real
I am so this is a complicated question
because like so Pinker's thesis as I
understand it is everything is getting
better and to make that case he points
to these historical trend lines and I
basically agree with that guy I agree
the world has gotten better in a bunch
of really important ways and I'm and I'm
pretty optimistic about those trend
lines continuing so in that sense yes
I'm like optimistic in the sense that
like my best trying to be accurate
guesses that things are gonna be good
the the like area of nuance that I want
to add though is that in my experience
Pinker is really resistant to the
argument that as things on average have
gotten better tail risks have also gone
up like as more powerful technology is
created or is beginning to be created as
the world becomes more interconnected
the impact of catastrophes can get much
bigger you know
nuclear war pandemics or things like
that and these are like real risks that
we should worry about and I my
impression has been that like tinker is
dismissive of these concerns because
they don't fit with the general thesis
that things are getting better to my
mind those are those two things are
completely consistent like things have
gotten better and will continue to get
better in a bunch of
important ways also risks are going up
but yes I mean I am generally pretty
optimistic about the future because it
seems warranted to me I just I just
worry about the discourse around
optimism where like I often see people
who are also optimistic for similar
reasons as me like praise optimism and
and condemn pessimism and I think that's
the wrong way to be conducting a
conversation like you should be making
the case for optimism you shouldn't be
saying yay optimists and boo pessimists
which could be affected like it's
totally a thing that people respond to
social incentive they don't want people
to think they're a wet blanket or you
know annoying or doomsayer things like
that and so you can in fact like
socially pressure people into having the
views that you think they should have
but you shouldn't do that you should
just make your case and you know if
you're right you'll be more convincing
to people so Andy we asked what shifts
our mentality from soldier to scout
maybe this would be a true phase
question what is education sort of
starting from blank slate not really but
you know how would you encourage
scouting us or at least openness to
scouting us and not just completely buy
into a solider mentality yeah so there's
two different ways you could address
this question one is over time how do
you shift someone sort of disposition in
general habits in a scout like direction
Scout word Direction a different
approach would be like in a given
situation like with my you know with my
book where I was like flinching away
from the possibility that people might
disagree with me how do you shift in a
given situation towards scout mindset
but I'll just I already sort of talked
about the latter one a little bit but to
focus on the former
so I had this graph of despair in my
talk there is a corresponding graph of
partial hope that I could have shared as
well it's also from kahan and it's and
it's also about like people's views on
the question of his global warming
happening but the x-axis instead of
being science literacy is science
curiosity which con measures in a bunch
of different ways
partly self reports from people but also
like how often do they go to science
lectures how often do they read science
books when you like give them a bunch of
materials to read do they read the
science thing things like that and that
graph is much less depressing because as
people go up the percentile scale of
science curiosity their views actually
converge slightly but they don't diverge
wildly the way they did in the science
literacy graph I'm so like the more
scientifically curious people are the
more likely they are to think that
global warming is real even though
Republicans are still less likely than
Democrats they're like going in the
right direction they're like moving
together so so then a question would be
like how do you encourage curiosity I
don't know a lot about that I know that
there are pretty convincing theories
about are this the way our sort of
standard educational system is set up
like quashing curiosity or squashing
curiosity early so to the extent that
schools are doing that to kids we could
stop doing that and that would probably
be helpful but in terms of like taking
an adult and making them more curious
it's I don't know exactly how to do that
well one thing I saw in all places
officer training in the Army was turns
out the function of an officer released
a small unit probably at every scale is
you have the unit doing the best you can
at the mission that's been given and
doing it the way it looks probably the
orders waited out you're supposed to do
and the sergeants and the troops are all
wailing we're doing this thing as good
as they can
and the officers job is to supervise
that and see if the fact that's
happening but also in a sense to kind of
Janice face look the other way in terms
asking the question is it possible that
the unit is diligently doing the wrong
thing well hmm and because it's so easy
to judge well you know this is going
well everybody bearing down and getting
advancing if it turns out to be in the
wrong direction right the wrong side of
the hill or there's not was part in unit
next to you like you thought it was
that's the officers job is to have that
basically larger perspective which has a
kind of a aggressive in creative doubt
it's almost Buddhist that you know what
if we are doing the wrong thing well hmm
it's traitors no it's not even yeah okay
[ __ ] it's just you this is all your
doing and they don't do they give you
some things get a chance to sort of try
that in real life it's basically true um
I think this is part of what good
judgment what's in Churchill listen you
know main thing you look for in a hire
or anything else or politicians they
have a good judgment mm-hmm there's very
few there's very little news I can tell
very few books about what is good
judgment how do you recognize great
judgment somebody how do you hire over
good judgment how do you change bad
judgment for good judgment which is part
of what your again again and Peter
Drucker always claimed the main thing
you look at is the track record the
person you're gonna hire and if they
have a bunch of documental successes
that's a pretty strong indication that
they have the kind of judgment that
would make the right thing keep
happening and you can hire for that and
expect the right thing will keep
happening anyway that's the story so far
yeah so the question you ask is where
you go next what's next for you I have
to finish this freaking book the the
current working title is the soldier in
the Scout why we deceive ourselves and
how to get things
right and what stage you have I turned
in the first draft
I'm waiting for my publisher to get back
to me with edits you got more choices
thank you I do have a couple other
things that I've kind of been excited
about and been putting off as I've been
writing the books and maybe at some
point in the near future
one thing is I've been focused mostly
and the time I've spent thinking about
thinking I've been thinking about
individual reasoning and judgment like
how do you as an individual decide what
information to collect and how to
evaluate it and when to change your mind
and so on
and I've just gotten increasingly
interested in group group reasoning what
how do you like assemble a group that's
going to be as accurate as possible what
kind of like norms do you have in the
group yeah it's a great question so if I
were to write a book at some point in
the future I can't even think about that
right now
it might be about group group scout
mindset and then another thing that I
got interested in while working on this
book and arguing with it about friends
is soldier versus scout mindset in the
history of science
so a an argument that some of my friends
have made named them because I don't
know if they'd want to be named but an
argument some people have made is
science actually benefits a lot from
soldier mindset you want people to be
these sort of Mavericks who have their
own crazy theories that they pursue and
they don't listen to anyone tell them
that you know the theory doesn't make
sense so that there are flaws and you
know most of them are just gonna be
crazy people so yeah so in this theory
right you you'd like want people to just
like not be
at all interested in whether the
theories are wrong in that way we get
this like big diverse exploration of the
space of possible theories which in this
model we wouldn't get if everyone was
like trying to be you know accurate and
reasonable I so this is what I've sort
of been doing in my free time when not
working in the book I well so for a
while between me and these friends it
was like a war of anecdotes where like
he would like give an example of a
scientist who was you know not very
Scott mindset and like turned out to
make Anna super important discovery and
I would respond with an example of a
scientist like Darwin who had a lot of
Scout mindset and that was really
valuable and then I was like this is
just this war of anecdotes is not gonna
settle anything I need some more
constrained way to like pick a
representative or good subset of
scientists and then just like look at
how much soldier scout like successful
scientists who made valuable
contributions and then just like read
their histories and how they what the
process was how they discovered the
thing they discovered so the thing I've
started doing is going on Wikipedia they
have a list of paradigm shifts in
various fields of science so like
Darwin's on there Newton Lavoie Zn and
I'm just reading about their process in
as much detail as I can to figure out
you know how how like intellectually
honest were they and and how much did it
matter and that's a project and I'm
excited about it is and the whole
process of a paradigm shift is social
right and there's but you came up with
an alternative
[Applause]
[Music]